he's just a few weeks into the job and
Thursday's Autumn statement could
already be career defining for the new
Chancellor well Jeremy Hunt has been on
the show already this morning he's
repeatedly told us that there will be
eye-wateringly difficult decisions made
on spending cuts and tax Rises with the
UK likely already in recession we spoke
to Jeremy Hunt about his plans for the
economy
before we get to the Autumn statement
how will you be reflecting this
remembrance Sunday well I'm going to be
remembering my father who died eight
years ago and was in the Navy all his
life
and I'll be thinking about him but also
I think all of us will be thinking about
the brave ukrainians who have been on
the front line Fighting For Freedom not
just for them but actually for all of us
and I think it's a reminder that we can
never be complacent if we want to defend
the things we really believe in is
defense spending something that you're
going to be prioritizing next week then
it's really important I will be talking
about it there are lots of things we
need to resolve when it comes to defense
spending but if you're asking is the
prime minister am I committed to making
sure that we can defend our country and
the values we believe in absolutely yes
uh now I do want to
um talk about what we can expect next
week and I want to do things a bit
differently because I know obviously
with these interviews you're very
limited in what you can say so rather
than just running through a whole load
of potential policies and you saying to
me I can't talk about them and I'm going
to try and keep things a bit more Broad
and if you could answer things as full
as you're able given obviously the the
concern that so many of our viewers are
frankly having at the minute with the
inflation costs and and potential
austerity to come as well and you've
warned of decisions of eye-watering
difficulty does this mean we are going
to be seeing a return to austerity
well they aren't going to be very
difficult decisions but we are a
resilient country and we've faced much
bigger challenges frankly in our history
and we know that to deal with problems
you have to face into them not run away
from them and we're also a compassionate
country and so a plan that I outlined to
the House of Commons on Thursday will be
one that gets us through these difficult
times but also shows that British
compassion the support for the most
vulnerable people and probably the
single thing that is the biggest worry
to people on low incomes actually to
everyone is the rising cost of bills
Energy prices going up and so we will
outline a plan to hold down the rises in
Energy prices and chart our way to a
longer term World in which we're not
dependent on what Putin does he can't
just suddenly see our gas prices shoot
up
having that long-term plan in place is I
think the way that we can give people
confidence that we'll get through this
so will there be a new plan on energy
because you're warning aren't you in
Sunday times today about the
sustainability of the current plan and
the man that's costing us well we Face a
global energy crisis uh the increase in
our national Energy bill over the last
couple of years is about 140 billion
pounds it's like the economy supporting
an entire second NHS
and if we're going to tackle that and
deal with the worry that for example a
pensioner has about the you know massive
increase in in the gas bill the
electricity bill and so on then we need
a long-term plan for the country for
clean energy for green energy for cheap
energy that isn't affected by
international events so absolutely I'll
be setting out that plan on Thursday and
you talk about pensioners is it likely
that support could be more targeted to
people who are more vulnerable but we
want to support people who need support
we don't want anyone not to be able to
afford to heat their home over this
winter or indeed future Winters but in
the long run what you need is a plan
that means that we don't need to have to
give very very expensive support as
taxpayers because we've got an energy
system that works better that that deals
with what dictators are doing in other
parts of the world it means that we're
not suddenly vulnerable to to big
changes in international gas prices so I
I want to outline the short-term support
that will give people who need it but
also a long-term plan to really change
our approach to energy
whole in the public finances that you
want to try and Shrink with a mixture of
tax Rises and spending cards it is
well we do have to do some tax Rises do
some spending cuts if we're going to
show that we're a country that pays our
way and the reason for that is is very
simple you know we were able to help
businesses through the furlough scheme
we've been able to help people with
their energy bills this winter we'll be
able to do so next winter because we've
been responsible with public finances
we're now in a situation where the world
has changed very dramatically over the
last year
but the plan that we'll outline will
help us get through this in a way that I
I want to make sure that this recession
if we're in a recession is as short and
shallow as possible and get through to
the economy growing healthily the other
side and that's the plan
that I think will give people confidence
and that's what I want to announce to
the House of Commons you say that you've
been responsible with the public
finances I just want to question if
that's actually true
um I think we can look at debt over time
debt levels and obviously I'd take your
point that I'm sure you'll say that you
know covid has come along and that has
affected things but actually the
increase in debt started before that you
can see here you know it's starting to
go up from around you know 2008 to 2009
and government debt is a percentage of
the economy has been high for some time
some people will be saying hang on the
conservatives have been in power for 12
years you're the ones who've actually
effectively trashed the economy got it
into the state we're in now but we've
had some very big shocks as you
mentioned a uh once in a century
pandemic now the situation in Ukraine
and and you'll find all countries all
over the world have seen their debt
levels increase in fact our debt level
is lower than many other countries many
other big countries across the world but
the question is not the absolute level
of debt so much as whether you have a
plan to bring it down responsibly over
time so that people can see just as
families have to make sure that in the
end they can pay their bills they don't
just max out on their credit card
without having any way of repaying those
debts it's just the same for countries
and we have to do that because if we
want to put more money into the NHS if
we want to help people are going to find
it very very difficult this winter then
we need to have the resources to do that
and that means that we need to take
difficult decisions even at moments like
this you've said that all government
departments will have to find more
efficiencies than planned so is that
true of every Department well a strong
Public Services which we all want need a
strong economy so you have to take
difficult decisions but it's also true
that a strong economy needs good Public
Services we need for example the NHS to
help people get back to work so we'll
approach this in a balanced way that
makes sure that we do everything we can
to keep the recession if we're in one as
short as possible and get the economy
growing as quickly as we can you
mentioned the NHS that I just want to
have a look at the latest figures for a
e at waiting times because this really
is
um pretty uh Stark this is the number of
people waiting more than 12 hours in a e
in England at four thousand forty three
thousand I should say 792
in October I mean frankly this doesn't
look like a Health Service that can find
efficiency savings this looks like a
Health Service that you know is on the
brink of collapse there are massive
pressures in the NHS obviously it's
something I know very well from previous
jobs I've done and I think that doctors
nurses on the front line are frankly
under unbearable pressure so I I do
recognize the picture you say it's also
true that there is a lot of money going
to the NHS and they will be the first to
say that in a context where funding for
the NHS is going up we need to do
everything we can to find efficiencies
but if you're saying to me the NHS is in
a very very tricky situation I agree and
you know I care passionately about the
NHS chess I spent more time thinking
about the NHS than any other public
service in my time in Parliament and we
need the NHS to help us get out of the
economic difficulties we're in because
as you'll see in other parts of the
Sunday papers we've got a big increase
in the number of people who aren't
working aren't taking part in work even
though they perhaps could and sometimes
that's as a result of long-term sickness
so the NHS is part of the solution as
well as facing some very big problems so
you're going to look at that
specifically to try and I guess look at
the benefit systems try and encourage
people back to work who you believe
could be working more we need to look at
all public services to make sure that
they're doing the right thing for the
economy we need to take these difficult
decisions but we need a balanced plan
and what I want to announce to the
country on Thursday is is not just the
difficult decisions but also to show the
way through and part of that is to show
that by tackling inflation early dealing
with these bills that are soaring for
families up and down the country we can
get back to Growing the economy
healthily so that we can invest the kind
of sums that we all want to in our
Public Services you talked at the
beginning about compassion and you've
also said that those with the broader
shoulders should be asked to Bear the
greatest burden how do you define people
with a broader shoulders
but I think we have to recognize that
people on the very lowest incomes
only have so much they can give we will
be asking everyone for sacrifices but I
think in a in a fair society as we are
in the UK we need to recognize that
there's only so much you can ask from
people on the very lowest income so that
will be reflected in the decisions that
I take and I think that's important
because Britain is a decent country a
fair country a compassionate country and
I want that to be reflected in the
decisions we take so you'll be paying a
bit more tax then after next week but
we're all going to be paying a bit more
tax I'm afraid Sophie
um but it's not just going to be bad
news I think what people recognize that
is that if you want to give people
confidence about the future you have to
be honest about the present and you have
to have a plan and this will be a plan
to help bring down inflation help
control high energy prices and also get
our way back to Growing healthily which
is what we need so much today's weather
shoulders include public sector workers
who were likely to be seeing real terms
cuts to their pay at a time when
inflation is a 10 well I'm very
conscious of the concerns for example of
nurses who are considering industrial
action at the moment and if you listen
to what nurses leaders say their concern
is about the impact of inflation on
their pay packet and the point I would
make conservatives know that a thriving
Dynamic economy needs low taxes and sell
money but sound money has to come first
because if you're a nurse it's inflation
that is eroding the spending power in
your pay packet it's meaning that your
weekly shop is becoming much more
expensive it's meaning that mortgages
are more expensive than they were and so
we need to do something that shows
public sector workers just as we show
everyone that we're getting back to a
low inflation economy where they don't
have to worry about bills getting higher
and higher do you agree with the health
secretary that nurses are asking for too
much well I think we have to recognize
a difficult truth that if we gave
everyone
inflation-proof pay Rises inflation
would stay we wouldn't bring down
inflation and that's why you know I'm
not pretending there aren't some
difficult decisions but what I want to
say to to nurses to everyone is that the
way through this is to bring down
inflation as quickly as possible because
that is the root cause of your concern
your anger your frustration that your
pay isn't going as far as it might and
you talk about difficult decisions and
you know and everyone being impacted but
I just wonder if that's true because you
know according to reports the triple
auction pensions will be protected so
pensions will be going up by 10 linked
to inflation do nurses have broader
shoulders than you know wealthy retirees
spending time on the golf course well I
think these are the questions you should
ask me after I announce what the
decisions are next week but
um I would say that there is a lot of
pensioner poverty a lot of pensioners in
very triple locks not means tested but
well very often pensioners need help and
it's not necessarily people on the very
lowest incomes but I think you have to
wait for the decisions and then we'll
see but I think what you'll see overall
is a broad approach that recognizes that
where we can we need to prioritize
people on the lowest incomes okay now
have you as you've acknowledged we are
most likely already in a recession
you're of course proposing to cut
spending and raise taxes two things that
can have a negative impact on growth I
just want to listen to in Duncan Smith
this is what he told our Deputy
political editor at Sam coats this week
if they try and hammers too hard with
tax Rises they will actually drive us
deeper into recession thus countering
the right objective and by the way any
deficit they think is there and by the
way these are just forecasts would
actually grow not shrink so they they
actually defeat the objective which is
what John Maynard Keynes told us many
years ago who don't raise taxes during a
course of a recession
he's worried that you could be driving
us deeper into recession is it right
well um I have a great deal of respect
for Ian Duncan Smith and um he
illustrates with some very important
points the very finely balanced decision
we have to make because he's absolutely
right you don't want to do things that
make any recession that you may be in
worse but on the other hand if if you do
nothing if you don't show that we're
going to bring our debt down over time
we've seen what happened before with the
the mini budget that happened interest
rates get higher and you get a recession
that's made worse because people
suddenly find the cost of their
mortgages are shot through the roof
businesses find that the cost of their
loans have become much more expensive so
you need to chart a balance course that
is doing the right thing to make sure
that the recession that we have by the
way the predicted fall in German GDP is
is much greater than the four here so
this isn't something that's just US
inflation is higher in Germany in in
Italy as well so all countries are
facing these challenges but if you're
saying to me do I want to act in a way
that makes this recession if we're in it
as short and shallow as possible
absolutely he's not the only
conservative MP he'll be concerned about
you know growth and about low taxes I
just want to play you a part of our
interview that we did when you were
running to be a conservative leader in
back in July it feels like a lifetime
ago but it was only a few months this is
a message that you were giving then
we are where we are and I think the
priority now is to go for growth for the
economy but I also think no conservative
should raise taxes so the cut the cuts
I'll make they're not particularly
retail I'm also someone who thinks that
we shouldn't just stop the corporation
tax Rises I think we should cut them so
that they're the lowest in Europe and
North America I want to cut it to 15 the
lowest we're able we're allowed to cut
it to according to International
agreements
cutting taxes going for growth what
happened to that guy well he's sitting
right in front of you Sophie and um look
I actually overall point I was making is
something that I hope you'll see
reflected in the decisions made on
Thursday which is to try and protect the
things that really matter for economic
growth but the world has changed since
the summer we've had a very big
deterioration in public finances in the
international situation I wish you seen
that to be fair was during that
leadership campaign describing is
prioritizing growth over inflation it's
fantasy economics well and he deserves
great credit for that because because he
said things like that that people didn't
want to hear he lost the conservative
leadership campaign and I think
subsequent events have proved that he is
absolutely right in the judgments that
he made at that time but what I would
say is
um the Jeremy Hunt you saw there saying
let's be the most competitive place for
businesses anywhere in Europe is the
same Jeremy Hunt that is now chance of
the exchequer and we need to absolutely
protect the things that for our
long-term growth
um just finally
um you mentioned when she seem like that
of course he used to do your job a
Chancellor and
he said to know what it is like you know
putting together a big fiscal event like
this with your boss the guy who used to
be Chancellor is a bit like someone
having someone you know looking over
your shoulder marking your homework for
you it's a great relief actually Sophie
because I've got someone who knows all
the things you can do that might go
wrong all the mistakes you you might
make inadvertently so we have exactly
the same approach on the big issues we
need to do what's right for long-term
growth we need to be prepared to take
difficult decisions if necessary but we
want to protect the vulnerable but in
terms of the detail this is someone
who's done my job extremely well and uh
that's a great support okay thank you
very much indeed thank you